our humans destined to live on earth
forever our settlements on other planets
even a realistic option and what if we
lived in space today on what if
discussed
[Music]
hello and welcome everyone to what if
discussed I'm Peter speechin and I'm
Richard Garner and Richard today we're
going to space hire ethically
theoretically hypothetically one thing
is as you'll find out during this this
show I'm not going well we'll see we'll
see at the end because I have a feeling
I'll be able to win you over I've got a
couple of pitches I'll save that for
later again just if you are joining us
wondering okay what if we lived in space
does that include the options of let's
say living on Mars living on Venus we've
talked about that in in what if
terraforming Mars terraforming Venus but
no not that's something we're talking
about in this show today we're talking
about mega structures mega structures
like the Death Star well yes the Death
Star will probably be referenced once or
twice today but specifically some of the
sort of more real ideas that you would
have seen in a lot of sci-fi over the
year 2001 Space Odyssey movies like
Elysium Babylon 5 like we've seen
versions of megastructures in space for
generally hundred two hundred people
stuff like that in Star Wars whatever
but we're what's been proposed by people
going back as far back as the 20s and
30s but especially in the last three or
40 years but is a hotter topic these
days with the Bond villains of you know
Elon Musk and Jeff Bezos Richard Branson
as well all discussing not just spit you
know travel talking about putting people
into structures and living in mega
structures for like forever
yeah Elon Musk by the way he's the chief
he'd be the chief I think no he looks
the part
Bezos would be more Blofeld yes I mean
that's central casting right who is
Richard Brett I don't know who Richard
brick Branson starts off as a villain
but turns good I think I think you know
he's got the you know the the nice
blonde hair or the whatever but he seems
to be I mean it's funny we talked about
this but it's interesting all these
types of personalities I don't know how
they would have been looked at when they
were talking about it oh go I'm thinking
to go into space well that was five six
years ago when they were successful in
other ventures whether be Amazon PayPal
initially
obviously Virgin Atlantic well now this
is real like people are hearing them not
just talk about their they've hired
people they're putting plans together so
it's not so much of a hypothetical if 20
or 30 years ago we're talking about this
this is crazy talk I'm not saying we're
close but you got people like that with
the money and with the will to be able
to at least start advancing the
discussions yes and apologies to those
three gentlemen obviously they're very
generous and very nice people we love
I'll be on the show yeah
yeah I don't think 20 or 30 years ago
this wasn't in the conversation but now
that we're building private rockets and
talking about sending people to Mars
it's it's something that's on the
horizon and the urgency I mean that's
the other the sort of the other variable
that's entered the conversation did you
have people I mean Hawking before he
died was talking about getting off this
planet at some point as as a you know
having a plan B for various reasons that
old that sort of life mode idea of
having options whether it was you know
we get hit by an asteroid or climate
change damage increases exponentially
whatever it is you do have people
seriously considering what would be the
option for this this human species
beyond you know the sort of the bonds of
Earth and that's something that was
always just sort of crazy hypothetical
talk not so much these days and and the
timeline is something that that it blows
people's mind to write because we're not
talking about you know five years into
the future or something this could be 40
years into the future yes we could be
talking a thousand years into the future
yeah and it may take even a thousand
years into the future it may take six
years to build it it may take a thousand
years to build it as well and that's we
don't have a good track record these
days I mean back in the day of let's say
FDR and the green New Deal long-term
infrastructure projects for the norm
yeah we're gonna build a bridge we're
gonna build the dam it's gonna be 15
years it's gonna be 20 years it's gonna
be we don't do that these days the
political cycle is too short generally
people want to fund things that they're
gonna be around to cut the ribbon at now
this is not gonna be that type of thing
I think it requires more than just one
country doing this requires a one-world
government which scares people obviously
or a dictatorship or I like to liken it
to you know the day
of the Pharaoh having his pyramids built
he enslaved the people to build his
pyramid is that what is going to happen
are we going to be enslaved because I'm
not gonna quit my job to go build a
space station for somebody to live in 50
years after I die
that's why would I do that I would hope
that that is not what is required yeah
I'm I am Negative Nancy on this I don't
know is this no no I mean I think that
it's it's beyond the grasp of what we're
at now so it's you know most people
would say I think we got bigger fish to
fry here and then this is where we would
want to sort of divert that level of
energy that level of thought and that
level of resource but there's also other
people that can make a case that it's
not the type of thing you want to say
afterwards you know what I wish we had
that option because now we don't it's
too late yeah yeah you're Bob Wow as
they say in come back and that means we
will see we will see well let's see
about our first guest dr. Rome K or
lobby Z has wanted to be an astronaut
ever since she can remember she earned
her first of many degrees in mechanical
engineering from MIT and a certificate
from the Russian Moscow Aviation
Institute in their manned mission to
Mars student exchange program she also
has a master's in mechanical engineering
and one in aeronautical engineering and
a doctorate she's currently a member of
100 year starship an initiative that
seeks to replicate the rapid
technological developments stimulated by
the moon landings by tackling human
interstellar travel dr. olla BC thanks
for joining us thank you for having me
so Peter and I were talking before the
show and we were saying that 20-30 years
ago this is a real hypothetical question
what if we lived in space but it feels
less hypothetical today you see more
people talking about we talked about the
big tech Titans Elon Musk and Jeff Bezos
really talking about sort of exploring
the possibilities of this how likely do
you believe it is that we will one day
be living in space well I mean that's a
great question but technically we have
been living in space since before I was
born in the
these since 1971 there have been 11
space stations that have had crews
living in them pretty much since then
for varying length of time the Russians
had value to one through seven although
two crashed and doesn't really count but
then there was mirror and then the US
has Skylab the Chinese had can grown one
and two and now we all have the
International Space Station so in terms
of how likely if you're considering that
we do then it's a hundred percent the
longest record of living in space was
set in 1995 that's four hundred and
thirty seven days so it's just if you're
talking about regular people living in
space and not astronauts like for primo
real estate I want to live in space
because this is cool I think you get a
good idea of what might happen if you
look at other extreme environments so
space is considered an extreme
environment because the environment
itself is going to kill you if you're
not really careful right
so without precautions just microgravity
just being weightless it affects every
single organ system in addition outside
of Earth's magnetosphere you're exposed
to a cosmic radiation at a much greater
rate so six months of cosmic radiation
on the space station is equivalent to 40
years of cosmic radiation on the planet
right and we don't really have anything
to block it in the same way that the
magnetosphere blocks it in the
atmosphere in space the microbiome is
very different the cycle of social and
psychological impact of being in an
isolated and confined environment is
really considerable and we have analogs
to that to see how people will do so
space very high altitude deep sea
Antarctica these are all extreme
environments and we have people who
occupy research stations in art Arctica
people who occupy deep-sea research
stations
and people who climb Mount Everest but
everybody who does these things they go
there for a purpose and then they leave
so they either go there to do research
like in Antarctica or tourism like Mount
Everest like hey I did that but they
don't live there just to be there it's
just too hard so I think with space it's
going to be the same we'll continue to
live there for brief periods but for
research purposes not just because I'm
so cool I let me read there have been
though megastructures proposed to take
many people out in space not much bigger
than research stations so like mega
structures like the Bernal sphere was
proposed in 1929 and more recently in
the 70s we saw the Stanford torus and
the O'Neill cylinder all these designs
for the mega structures they differ but
they all have one thing in common they
all rotate why is that well to counter
the effects of microgravity astronauts
they have to exercise pretty much four
hours a day too you want to maintain
their bone mass your bodies this really
amazing optimization machine and it
decides okay clearly I don't need bones
or muscle and it starts getting rid of
them like this is such an optimal
environment and why am i supporting it
why am i supporting all of these extra
systems that I don't need anymore
so it you began to extreme calcium
because your your skeleton is
essentially this Bank of calcium that
you can draw from or put back and it
decides I don't need to maintain all of
this anymore let me excrete this and it
puts you at risk for kidney stones
because you urinate it out there's this
headward fluid shift because gravity's
not pulling on the fluids in your body
anymore and it gives you a killer
headache on the first few days but then
you know later it results in your
buddies like I have I color we have so
much fluid since there's so much in my
head so it makes you urinate all with
what it perceives as extra fluid out and
the result is that when you return to
Earth you don't have enough blood under
gravity
to remain conscious and a lot of
astronauts will suffer what they call
orthostatic intolerance which just means
that you can't stand upright without
passing out and so when you see them
coming back from a really long duration
you'll very rarely ever see any of them
standing on their own they'll be carried
your vestibular system it needs gravity
to function correctly and some people
get extremely motion sick from the lack
of this gravitational input so stationed
most motion sickness they have a unit
for it and it's called
the Garn and it's named after senator
jake garn he flew on the shuttle
discovery of the Congressional observer
and one cortázar is considered very sick
one full Garn is and I quote as sick as
it is humanly possible to be so like
these things happen because your your
whole organ system was designed in
gravity to work in gravity the heart
changes because there's no gravity
pulling on your blood to help the heart
out their vision changes that they
believe are caused by the fluid shift
that is caused by microgravity
so everything pretty much changes and
there are countermeasures for all of
these changes the exercise the the diet
the the different pills but the emia
countermeasure to do is gravity so if
you rotate your habitat you experience
what feels like gravity and then you
don't have to do all of these other
things when it would a full a full
garner would do that terms of making you
say oh yeah well I don't know that
sounds that sounds awful honestly all
most of that sounds incredibly
challenging obviously Peter and I both
know the answer to this question but for
the people at home what is the
difference between centripetal force
force and centrifugal force is that
convincing centrifugal its centrifugal
because obviously I think a lot of
people have heard centrifugal but not
necessarily centripetal so
let's just like to say that like the
with the s because I want to be clear
speaking over the to hear centrifugal is
not a real force where a centripetal is
a real source so centripetal means
Center seeking so if I take a string
with a ball and swing it around in a
circle right the ball is going in that
circle because of the tension in the
spring and that that string is exerting
a centripetal force on the ball it's
pulling it inward and so Center speaking
and so that ball if you let go of that
string the ball is going to go in a
straight line it's not going to keep
curving around right so you need you
need that force and entering the center
or seeking the center it's constantly
pulling it and so that that ball is
constantly accelerating because it's
acceleration is change in velocity so
it's constantly changing its forward
velocity to a different angle right and
so centrifugal force it's something that
you feel but it's considered not real
because it's really just the inertia of
the object there's no real force pulling
outward on that ball it's just that ball
really wants to go straight so if I'm
pulling that ball the force the ball
wants to go this way but the force is
pulling it this way and so it's pulling
it it's pulling it it's pulling it so
it's not that if there were a true
centrifugal force it would pull it this
way but if I let go of that string that
ball goes that way and so it's just this
equal and opposite reaction that happens
in a non inertial reference frame so
when you're in an inertial reference
frame which means a frame that's not
moving when you're in an inertial
reference frame you never see
centrifugal force when you're in a non
inertial reference frame it is an
apparent force so like if if you're say
driving in a car and you turn left it
feels like you're
you want to go right but it's not that
you're really going right is that your
body wants to continue on the path that
it was going and so your body wants to
continue going straight but since your
reference frame is turning left to you
it feels right and I don't know if that
makes it more confusing it's just it's
it's just this this force that seems to
you like if if you're in that car it
seems to you like you're going right but
if somebody is looking down on you
because them it seems to them like
you're continuing straight so if you're
in this rotating habitat your inertia
makes you feel like you're being pushed
into the ground in that habitat the same
way turning left makes you feel like
you're being pushed to the right I don't
know exactly how I would explain that's
what we were thinking that's exactly
what we were thinking except we were
usually a little bit more concise about
it but thank you for your explanation
when we talk about living in mega
structures in outer space we there's a
lot of upsides to it we can live in a
climate-controlled
area where it's always nice you know
unlimited energy from solar panels and
the Sun we can grow our own food locally
we're talking about maybe no economy no
money or anything like that but there
are downsides and specifically I'm
thinking of space debris like asteroids
meteors meteorites what are the dangers
of living in space well I'm going to say
[Music]
but you don't have really any danger
from meteors or meteorites
so meteoroids are space debris like
asteroids meteors are meteoroids that
are burning up in Earth's atmosphere so
technically if you're in Earth's
atmosphere you're no longer in space and
meteorites are meteors that hit the
earth but so I'm not gonna be that nerdy
so I'm not gonna point out that
difference so I'll just just just in
case you want but science fiction movies
which I love what they do like
to depict asteroid belts is these very
dense places of floating rocks that are
all around and you have to dodge them
but in reality they're really very
sparsely packed they're supposed to be
like a hundred thousand asteroids that
are one kilometer inside and it's
estimated that these have one collision
like every few billion years all right
so maybe two in the lifetime of an
entire solar system but in fact when
NASA was trying to get close to an
asteroid just to take a picture with
Galileo it really required some
considerable effort to just navigate and
and find one and go near one the
voyagers and the pioneers that went in
that direction they went through the
asteroid belt they didn't even need to
be directed to avoid anything so they
didn't even need any kind of collision
control now that being said those are
for the larger ones the Pioneer
spacecraft were hit a couple of times by
some micrometer sized meteoroids
but you know they were still functioning
they weren't harmed but with humans so
like as size goes down the number of
particles goes up the number of
asteroids are increases so if you get
hit with a micrometer sized meteor or
meteoroids so you've got me saying it
then that could harm a person yes
but for the most part it's going to hit
your spacecraft and you want to know if
the tiny hole is punched in something
you want to know if you have an air leak
and it's not the same as as again in
science fiction movies where you just
have this explosive release of gas but
that's not going to happen with a tiny
hole what's gonna happen is you're gonna
feel did my ears just pop I feel like
we're losing pressure it's going to be a
very slow leak because you don't have
the sudden explosion of air that
depicted in fiction movie so like you
know when a rock hits your windshield
it's small rock small rock you got a bit
of a thing but you can still drive it's
a size thing it's it now you talked
about the human body and I knew you have
a unique level of expertise in that area
you talked about the challenges of being
in space for extended periods of time I
know that most of this the hypothetical
around living you know with millions or
billions of people in space and
megastructures they haven't really
gotten down to really sort of exploring
and immersing themselves in is it
possible long-term physically for the
human body to sustain it
do you believe even hypothetically that
there are environments that can be built
that can mitigate some of the things you
were talking about earlier and allow us
to live in a mate in a mega structure
like the O'Neill cylinder or the
Stanford torus for extended periods of
time or is it too much for the visit for
the human body well so the space station
is a great test bed to that and that's
what they're doing up there they're
testing that and what we know so far you
know a we can live 437 days in space so
we know we can live in that environment
but we also know that it's not the same
as Earth it they they were able to
develop these candidates for Salmonella
vaccine because some viruses get more
virulent in space the microbiome is
different the food is packaged its
intended for storage it's it's headed
for long duration so it's everything
that's going on in your gut is different
than what is happening on earth cosmic
radiation we still don't have any
effective barriers for except the
magnetosphere and the atmosphere and you
know pilot and people who live in
absolutes high altitude places like
Denver where there's less protective
atmosphere they have more incidences of
cancer so there are a lot of things to
figure out before living in space is a
real option but I mean all of that
having been said we have been living in
Faison for 74 about a year at a time the
idea for the Stanford torus originally
was to collect solar energy and beam it
back to earth and then solar power
companies with
sell it to the to the people on earth
but in order for this to happen we'd
have to have people up in space building
it and we'd have to have residences for
them and also there was talk of the
materials coming from mining the moon so
is a full time settlement on the moon a
possibility is that in in coming up well
so if we're thinking of this as leap
frogging from from a full time
settlement to the solar generators to
things like that we don't really need a
solid element to build these faithful
power generators we don't need any kind
of settlement at all
the US companies there are Chinese
companies there's the Chinese government
Japan all of them are really looking
seriously at building these photovoltaic
arrays and these would be developed in
space to collect sunlight to convert it
into microwave energy to beam that
energy down to earth and it would be
much cheaper to do this in the form of
deployable satellites that are modular
then to build settlements to then build
them so whether we need settlements on
the moon to build a Stanford torus we go
to Space Station without having that but
the key was the assembly so we can
assemble things in in space really fine
but when you have the full power of our
manufacturing industry on earth it's
easier to build on earth than to build
in space it's easier to just build and
then give it the completed device up
there and then have the astronauts
assemble it so requiring manufacturers
to be astronauts or astronauts to be
manufacturers it's just a recipe for
disaster there's a huge level of space
working a huge level of stress working
in living in space and and just just
having the units in place the
manufacturing than the transport and
then the assembly and knowing
you can do this in the least stressful
way possible it's just it's not a good
idea to try to combine all this things
to build something to be built in space
to be put together by people who are
stressed out that they are afraid that
any mistake they made with this assembly
is going to kill them and so that having
been said all of that having been said
3d printing has been a game changer so
you can 3d print metal and you can use
bioengineering to grow materials and
these may give additional options where
you're not having to have this
manufacturing industrial complex up
there you can grow these things in an
automated fashion and then assemble so I
think assembly is the key and I do think
that growing using bioengineering to
grow things is more likely than mining
the moon witching use bacteria to grow
plastic we can develop these things in
insight and I think that probably
probably more viable option than trying
to do these things by vise because you
would have to go and see what the moon
had you would have to go and smelt the
things that you need you would have to
set up a manufacturing complex on the
moon or you could have a vat of bacteria
so so Pete Richard's moon mining
operations not going to happen
I thought was a good idea on paper we'll
just we'll just keep trying to come up
with stuff yeah well hey listen we're
gonna need we're gonna need consultants
we're gonna need experts here you from
what I understand since you were a young
girl wanted to be an astronaut not sure
if that's true you you read stuff online
if that's the case and let's say all of
the things we've talked about somehow
have been fixed we've figured them out
we're 20 30 years ahead and somehow
we've we've ironed out all the wrinkles
would you personally if you had the
opportunity be one of the first people
to agree to live in
well it depends on how long you mean so
live forever and ever and ever in space
oh I could come back if I could come
back definitely well yeah I mean who
wouldn't I just it would be yes I've
always wanted to be an astronaut yes it
would be a wonderful wonderful dream but
I've always perceived of it as going up
there to work in space so particularly
because when you ask people would you go
and live in Antarctica most of them
would say why you know so it's an
isolated and confined environment now if
it were something like where we've got
these the Elysium kind of Stanford in
there developed tourists you know and
it's it's all fully developed and fully
deployed yeah is there but it's not
going to be like that for my lifetime so
I would just go there come work and then
come back yeah I I suspect you're right
and we'll defer to you on this one
we really appreciate you joining us
today because obviously we've learned a
lot and again like I said earlier this
is the place to go full-on nerd so we
appreciate the level of depth and
comprehensive insight because that's
actually what the the people who are
watching and listening want where can
people find out more about 100 yss and
your work 100 is f dot org is the URL
I'm listed on the University of
california-irvine
biomedical engineering department site
and it lists a little bit of what I do
and 100-year starship it if you want me
to talk a little bit about that please
yeah
if you
so I'm going to talk about it by backing
up and talking about the moon landings
right and so we landed on the moon in
1969 if you think about a hundred years
before if you think about 1869 everybody
would have thought that was science
fiction too but if you ask them then
well let's make sure we have all of the
technology in place to do this pretend
it's not impossible let's just do it in
the less than a decade since we decided
to go to the moon and then did it the
technological developments that came
from it like we have scratch resistant
glasses because they had to go to the
moon we have water recycling because
they needed to recycle their water to go
to the moon we have shoe insoles because
the astronauts needed that we had
cordless tools because they had no place
to plug it in there are so many things
like like even even communication
satellites we have we are zooming now we
have cell phones we have like satellite
television satellite radio because of
the development that happen from going
to the moon so it completely we're
really living in a space age everything
you've NASA has a site where you can go
and you can look at all the things that
you have in your household because we
went to the moon and it really
stimulates advancement in technology
having a goal that is so far beyond what
we have ever done and those goals push
technology so the the the hundred year
starship it's it's more of an idea than
can we really make it there so let's
pretend that it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter whether or not we make it
there what matters if we have the
technology required to make it there so
what does that look like what visit
technology looks like well to make it
there we need better energy is that
going to help us on earth so yeah
to make it there maybe we need to spend
earth animation can I imagine anything
for which that would happen on earth
yeah you need a rare operation and
you're not
to make it because the person is too far
away so you put your in suspended
animation and you can wait for that
surgery or you can wait for those
resources and so there are a variety of
things that going - the whole idea is
let's make sure we have what we need to
go to another star in a hundred years
and that requires transformational
technology and the goal is for that
transformational technology to improve
life on Earth well and again sort of
even to reiterate the point earlier this
is the place for Big Ideas right I mean
that's that's you and me we got the big
idea what it is but you would like to
hear vision alright and that's that's
the cool thing because to your point the
things we don't think we could do in a
hundred years we will be doing and
that's always been the case throughout
history so thanks thanks for reminding
us of that and again thanks for joining
us today on what if discussed yeah have
a great day at the beach yes yeah well I
certainly hope she gets some surfing in
or something today because that looked
like a great day at the beach um what do
we learned that we didn't already know
from that one a lot like I mean that you
know in the sort of the deep dive that
we do and we do a deep dive before we do
these shows we watch the would at videos
you know it was definitely more focused
on the actual structures themselves the
feasibility the cost what she really was
able to sort of focus me on was being
reminded that it's very difficult for
the human body to be in space yeah I
didn't know that stuff about gravity
that I thought the reason for gravity is
just so that we could have a solid
ground to walk on but it turns out it's
because of all the fluids and mostly
because when you return to Earth so that
you you your body can react better when
you get back to earth I wonder if there
was no gravity if we and we lived
forever out in space would there be much
of a difference yeah and she talked
about Scott Kelly who I believe is the
you know it's got the record now for
living in space for and I was like 400
plus year days which you talk to an over
a year which you know when you think
about it you're like oh that's crazy
like I mean you know you're up in a
space station for over a year I mean
obviously we've talked a lot about
isolation in the past three months
everywhere people have talked about how
difficult that is imagine being in a
space station for that long now that's
an entirely different environment but if
we're talking about living on these
types of megastructures for years
decades even you have to essentially
eliminate all of the problems that
affect the physical body like whatever
you have to figure out it has to be like
living on earth like atmospherically
gravity wise and I don't know I don't
know if we're close to being able to
replicate the conditions here in a mega
structure speaking of the mega
structures she talked about how we
wouldn't actually build them out in
space got I so I always thought okay
we'd send astronauts up there and they'd
be in spacesuits and they'd be yeah but
apparently that's not how it's going to
go so if that's not how it's going to go
and we have to prefabricate because here
on earth and send them up to space I
can't see us ever building an O'Neill
cylinder that can hold a million people
doing it at that rate like I say it
seems to me like it would take a hundred
million years
well she referenced the Space Station's
right and I get again I don't know but
you can google it you know how long did
it take to build the ISS how long did it
take to build you Mir and all those
things yes but those are for ten people
math like where I'm going in like I mean
and if you look at them they're you know
I don't their incredible accomplishments
relative to what we're seeing in these
proposed mega structures it's it's an
anthill versus you know a multiplex
condominium these things that you're
talking about here that are rotating in
space that can accommodate that's a
massive undertaking that again to your
point scope why size-wise all that so
yeah she was right we've lived in space
technically for decades but we're not
talking about that really we're talking
about not having the whole sort of space
station thing replicated with few people
we're talking about being able to live
there as an extension of Earth so we're
not I don't want saying we're
light-years away from that but we're not
closed in my opinion yeah and it better
be an extent
of Earth otherwise I'm not going because
yeah I've got all I need down here like
and my other thing is is like so I
talked a bit about like Eid the only
reason I would want to leave earth as if
death was imminent but also like seems
like a huge expense like couldn't that
expense also be spent on fixing this
shiny blue marble in space you know
instead of spending 47 billion trillion
dollars how much would it cost to fix
our problems down here yeah and not
politically you'd have a very difficult
time to be able to justify the cost of
this when people are saying exactly what
you just said what like you're proposing
something that's going to cost and we've
seen estimates of 600 to 900 billion
dollars and those are just pulled out of
the sky I'm sure it's more than that
nobody knows and how would you justify
that unless again like that's ultimately
this sort of catch-22 is you're gonna
need an eminent level threat to create
the urgency to get it done
but with the long arc it takes to build
one it's never going to be able to be
done that quickly so it's either you
build it as a lifeboat or you don't
build it we're never gonna see it I mean
in our lifetime even if it does get
built and it probably will it's not
gonna happen I see it in a few hundred
years well we hope you enjoyed our
hypothetical trip to outer space if you
enjoyed your time here and want to find
out more well why don't you check out
our extended audio version click on the
link in the description below will speak
to one of the leading presenters on
astronomy and space exploration Jerry
stone about the benefits of moving our
civilization into space until next time
until next time thanks very much we'll
see you next time on what if discussed
you